today my friends we have gathered to
talk about click bait
i mean obviously we've tried to step up
our clickbait game we've seen the
results
and i think we should just pitch some
ideas here to get ahead of it so we
don't have to discuss it on the show so
i have some ideas you guys have some
ideas or you guys want to pitch to me
first about uh we fed lovebot to an
alligator
i mean would an alligator eat a robot i
just don't know if that's like viable if
it's since when does the clickbait have
to be realistic well there needs to be
some element of realness you know
because they eat them with the outer
space nobody's going to click that it's
not realistic
ethan mukbangs to an early grade that's
actually what's happening realistic
that's what's happening it's not
clickbait that's like saying ethan is a
is a human being i think it's like
obviously okay yeah um i got the worst
thing i've ever done and we framed you
like a murderer like you did something
really bad the worst thing i've ever
done um it's okay he needs to be more
specific
zach died
that's good but would anyone i mean
would people call that's clickbait yeah
i don't know if that's clickbait yeah
like okay i guess how i know i mean i
feel snow i would care but the fans
wouldn't care yeah
mean zack box
guys come on step it up what do you what
else the new host of frenemies and it's
you and
wendy williams oh that's good
and instead of talking we just fart yeah
what else what else what else what else
come on come on
what about uh like ethan got arrested we
did that that was good one what about
like ethan retired maybe we did that
that was that's what you want
what about like
something bad happened and you're like
in a hospital we did that one yeah and
it was great yeah where you been it's
like why we've
clickbaited everything no there's
there's that we have ideas
i'm bald the truth
not quickly the truth about my hairline
yeah i wouldn't even joke about that his
hairline's too good nobody would believe
that all right dude you guys are
slacking
i have ideas for clickbait keemstar
kidnapped my son and is holding him
ransom
oh that's what the [ __ ] that's that's
cool you're telling me why didn't you
click that you're saying mine is too far
i i'm just okay all right maybe that
one's too far
you shouldn't joke about that using a
machete to remove my manhood
live like you know the bmp olympics yeah
live so it's not bad
you take a machete
i stretch it out
one shot
i don't think it's fair to call it live
it's a recorded episode so i i feel like
you think the live is too far that's
what's too far yeah
one machete one shot boom if you want to
do that on after dark by all means but
this is not a thumbnail for off the
rails the crew did the crew smoke sweet
how about the crew tres free basing
heroin
and then in parentheses um let's say uh
olivia ods i don't know how
my parents would feel about she still
lives there you're not gonna die it's
just clickbait you'll pretend to be
overdosed i don't want like you know
people thinking that i'm dead it's not
we're not doing heroin right right
it's just clickbait the island boys are
coming on the show
okay okay okay how about this one the
lady alec baldwin shot three
m jesus wait i didn't finish 3 a.m ouija
board
challenge emotional spooky
that made it worse too far yeah but you
would click that start of our ghost
hunting series yeah we ouija board yeah
we ouija board people who died
tragically what else you got a b hunk
himself not clickbait jesus
that one's not bad my wife's okay with
that i'm okay with it i'm calling ela
lina said she's fine with this i'm
calling eli okay
we may have to break the glass for this
trisha paytas no no no no no no no no no
no to leave yeah oh let me finish it's
not as bad as it sounds trisha paytas
skinned my dogs and made chairs out of
them not as bad as it sounds i like that
i'm telling you people click that but no
i don't want to joke about my dogs like
that maybe that maybe i'll veto that one
okay but you know what just in case of
emergency we've got that all set up
there
ian are we ready no no no
don't break it not yet okay why don't we
just do like me and ela
or breaking up or something like that
we're getting divorced i mean that's
pretty good right we haven't done that
before have we done that before ian
vaguely
so we're gonna go all in on this one
and this sketch is basically all we need
as premise so me and ela are breaking up
that's the title it works believable
yeah sure definitely believable two
hello hello hello welcome to off the
rails 17. we are here
uh obviously you know making guest goofs
about the uh uh me and hila getting
divorced
um
now listen i'm not gonna tell you right
up front that we're not getting divorced
i'll tell you at the end
[Music]
how are we gonna do with them
oh god
men
what are we gonna do
and we're doing impossible things
masculinity
wow
what are we gonna do
beautiful
a symphony
for angels uh
in heaven itself yeah so if you want to
know if me and ela are actually going to
be separating watch till the end where
i'll be revealing that right and you
can't skip forward
no no you have to don't skip because you
know there's surprises throughout the
show
yeah thank you everybody
today's episode is sponsored by curology
and liquid iv
also want to announce
that teddy fresh's huge
black friday sale
is going up this thursday
at 10 a.m
30 to 50 percent off
almost everything
[Music]
teddyfresh.com
thursday this thursday 10 a.m
it's always crazy the black friday sales
crazy oh [ __ ] look i didn't know look at
this our website's down in preparation
oh
my god so today if you're watching
non-members right this episode will be
going up tomorrow which is thursday yeah
when you by the time you watch this
it'll be live wow unless you're a member
wow pretty cool huh pretty cool one of
the perks
it's like time travel
it's like that
[Applause]
it is time travel
so yeah it's it's going to be
gangbusters it's going to be off the
chain get there early if you want to get
the good stuff
and um
that's what i can go black friday baby
yeah you know um
tired i have a funny theodore story
does it involve poop
no poop this time dan okay he's actually
quite regular now
he's back on track
yeah theodore was suffering from like
really bad constipation but um
through
through faith
power faith in god
and laxatives and fiber
we've got him back on track my friends i
pooped my pants
is that crowder
no uh al roker oh i'll roll correct he
pooped his pants right right right
yeah so theodore's been sleeping in our
bed lately
since um
oh hold on keem hold on we just got this
breaking update about keem's new
thumbnail
bunnies rest in peace wow
keemstar's going for it man his
channel's gotta survive
i like the little x's over the bunny's
eyes the bunnies are dead and then logan
paul's blushing i mean it's better than
the thumbnails he's been doing
maybe he took the criticism to heart
bunnies rip yeah so there's like a whole
story
i'm not going to get into it i'm just
going to give it context
rabbit gate
yeah
you know about rabbit i don't really
really no
yes so
we
i don't know if you want to do it now
but we have in the dog keemstar uh
explaining it he does a good job i don't
know if you want to keemstar explaining
rabbit game keemstar yeah explains
rabbit gate
really yeah
let's see all right let's watch it then
i mean
trisha he's crying dude keemstar i was
just about to tell a nice story about
theodore and now i'm already onto
keemstar crying about views roll it here
let's watch keemstar describe rabbit
gate
okay let me let me get this straight
trisha paytas
is under fire right now all right
because there was a scene in her vlog
where she by the way this is this is
keemstar [ __ ] i don't think anyone's
really mad about it other than like a
few people on like
read it
but now keemstar turns into a big story
rabbit gate showed her brand new
dining room table and the chairs had
rabbit fur on the back
and
her entire audience and a bunch of
people online you know the hate mob are
like calling her out for uh murdering
eight rabbits how dare you murder eight
rabbits for your dining room table
you're horrible trisha
trisha gets so much hate that she like
deletes that section out of her vlog
and i'm looking at this and i'm thinking
to myself
these are the same [ __ ] that
were watching trisha paytas just eat
chickens
eating chicken sandwiches eating
hamburgers murdering cows left and right
you didn't say [ __ ] about the cows you
didn't say [ __ ] about the chickens
species
you didn't eat
[ __ ] about the lamb chops she was eating
we love vegan keem
this is awesome
murdering them just
there's a couple rabbits oh that's a big
deal what the [ __ ] is the difference
wait where's the one where he goes [ __ ]
animals
it's a follow-up so someone responds to
him
there's no way he's screaming take it
back not based keem wait hold on hold
hold on okay because there wait
so there's yes so this is the response
someone responded to him saying this
okay but so i think the point i think
why people are mad though is because
dude i don't know it's people are weird
right we have a weird world with animals
like you can't [ __ ] eat dogs in
america if you eat a dog people lose
their [ __ ] mind because we love dogs
right
and bunnies are cute too so people have
kids bunnies for pets we love bunnies
also that i think harvesting fur is done
particularly and humanely right i mean i
don't think the the animals in in
slaughterhouses are living uh that's
exactly what extraordinary lives i mean
it's the slaughterhouses are horrific
all right but apparently bunnies when
their fur is harvested um
they get electrocuted or something
and also like
usually animals that give them the chair
yeah they just get a little rabbit chair
usually uh
animals that are bred for fur are like
freak genetics
like they get
bred and mutated into like these freak
living suffering boy do i have bad news
about chickens
yeah well yeah yeah right you're i know
all every animal who's uh raised
for our consumption it does lives a life
of of tragedy fear and suffering it
seems a little arbitrary to draw the
line at the bunny first i think i think
the real problem is that people like
bunnies and they have bunny pets well
also one of the criticisms is one of
them's for consumption and one's just a
decoration in this particular situation
okay that's a good that's and that's a
better distinction yeah that's a good
distinction
why do you see pull up a picture of the
clip i'll just show it since we're
getting into it what the [ __ ] there's
also like a huge difference between i
think people disconnect food because it
looks like food versus like that's the
fur of a bunny
that i've like seen right they're able
to abstract the meat that's sitting in
front of them it's not an animal at this
point uh whereas the the fur it's like a
in your face reminder of the animal that
it used to be absolutely i think that's
a huge part of it you know if you
went to the grocery store and you saw
like a whole cow
right that would probably freak people
out wait did she oh she went vegan oh my
god wait
she went vegan this morning apparently
i'm officially vegan
whoa whoa whoa whoa six hours earlier
six hours earlier eating greasy kfc
bucket by myself and my rolls royce in
the parking lot yeah fried chicken
wednesday baby that title is kind of
epic like i can't really hate on that
title eating a greasy kfc bucket by
myself and my rolls royce in the parking
lot is kind of like the greatest title
ever
and then six hours later i'm officially
vegan
[ __ ] fried chicken i mean good if
that's true then i wish her
a good journey for sure
here's the um here's the clip just to
give you guys some context i think the
other part is that
there's a unit there seems to be a
unanimous decision when it comes to
furniture and fashion that uh we we are
phasing out the use of animal fur
because faux fur is just basically come
to the level where
it's so good you can't even distinguish
right the difference right so it's like
what is there's basically no reason to
actually just
and i by the way people say well you
kill that rabbits and edom
so obviously you're gonna use the fur
those are different rabbits you have
rabbits for fur this is how they harvest
rabbits and you have fart rabbits for
eating and the rabbits that you eat i
think they just destroy their [ __ ]
body so bad i doubt you could even do
anything with the fur
no you probably make animal food for it
or something i'm just right right and at
the very least
i haven't seen any rabbit dog foods
and i have two dogs but yeah i think
it's probably awesome people don't like
the idea of eating rabbits dude this
[ __ ] is so
i'm just looking into it so messed up
right what how to how to get rabbit fur
yeah i'll read it well educate us not
reading i'm just looking at images it is
uh well yeah you can describe it to us
don't they like keep them alive for as
long as they can to keep the fur fresh
is that right
i don't know i don't know anything about
harvesting
[Music]
do my research
fact check yourself i know they do that
to dogs in like china which is just i
[ __ ]
and you know i i know i have that
cognitive dissonance because obviously i
eat meat but when i hear about like
people like the people in asia southeast
asia eating dogs
and the way that they kill them and
prepare them it just makes me it just
makes me so upset so yeah in the u.s
like chickens and turkeys rabbits are
excluded from the humane methods of
slaughter act a federal law that says
animals must be rendered unconscious
before being killed
rabbits may be killed by any of the
following methods uh neck breaking uh
striking the head with a blunt object
decapitation okay okay all right so yeah
yeah so basically the rabbits are not
being treated nicely by anyone it's not
hello
[Music]
yeah that's actually sounds like that
but we don't eat rabbits i mean in some
countries they eat rabbits and people
eat rabbits here in the states yeah i
think it's not common well not commonly
yeah i think it depends on where you are
too but i mean it's not people that
people that that hunt regularly uh
certainly eat rabbit
[Music]
well anyway it's obviously like you know
it's obvious that there's some cognitive
dissonance going on here with the
with the getting triggered over the
rabbit skin thing but there's also some
i can understand the argument on some
sides as well
but regardless there is a conversation
happening nice
cut there
what did i do something no ian just i
think accidentally faded to me
and by the way trisha if you're watching
this and you're angry i wouldn't even be
talking about this if it wasn't for
keemstar doing it on dramaalert i didn't
even plan to talk about this this is
keemstar's fault he did this to you
don't act like you are gone i'm getting
two very different answers in the whole
[ __ ] world
i'm getting one that says absolutely not
and then the second one says many cows
are still alive as they're being skinned
so i'm not cows or rabbits well this
says cows i just looked up animals got
it oh yeah that's so [ __ ] up horrible
it's horrible
yeah and again it's like
yeah this one says like human skin cow
skin naturally rots so they like like
human skin
i guess like a website
yeah microphilia
it's not pita one if we're being honest
with ourselves it's pita too oh it's
pedo yeah
oh pita too yeah okay
all right here's the video i didn't
realize there was a sequel let's see
cares like they're literally just so
perfect you can see we have our little
guests right here
but you can slide them out they're
exactly the same as the movie they're so
cool they have these really yeah by the
way
they i mean yeah it's
going on this cliff right now they have
they still have the rabbit ears by the
way
i think they just gutted that board they
have these really tall and narrow
seats and what is this
bird
so she said can i say that and moses was
like of course
so yeah
yeah so this is their beetlejuice room i
guess
you know
i love the movie beetlejuice
but
not um not a model to follow well isn't
the whole
it's been a while since i've seen
beetlejuice however isn't the whole
thing with
all of the artwork
is the stepmom's artwork and the whole
like joke is like it's really gaudy and
awful like she she has terrible taste
so to like embrace that and then just
like fill your home with all these
things that like i feel like it's kind
of missing
yes
a little bit it is because it's meant to
be awful disgusting freak [ __ ] and
trisha is like i'm gonna i want that
right i'm gonna kill those rabbits and
i'm gonna make that well in the rabbit
part yeah i just mean like the statue in
the background it's like
it's being made fun of in the movie for
being so stupid is it not like
well regardless of the audience
you definitely didn't have to kill the
rabbits uh you didn't have to kill the
rabbits looks like she took more than
five percent of those rabbits
got him for sure
he takes five percent of that rabbit
so that's it and i don't know what's
going on with this costume
people have been wondering i am totally
not in communication with moses or
trisha i don't know anything about
what's going on in their lives
i don't know anything about the wedding
we are not attending the wedding because
i see people questioning about that
this tweet seems
i wish them peace and love
and a happy uh
you really tried to edit this out too
bad we got it forever you and moses
support animal cruelty and then they tag
like what's peter gonna ten different
people what are they gonna do did peter
tweet about them they they love this
[ __ ]
hmm
peta's gotta be on this right they can
do a whole campaign about this i guess
they might be
but this is the drama it's rabbit gate i
see both sides
but obviously keemstar is a psychopath
here's his robot
for having
rabbit fur chairs right and i bring up
the point saying well uh how come you
didn't call her out for murdering the
chickens when she was eating the chicken
sandwich murdering the cows when she's
eating the hamburgers how can you call
her out then huh huh huh and you say oh
well it's a difference one you use for
substance you know energy for your body
and the other one she just murdered it
for a chair okay [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] you're really gonna reply to
me on a [ __ ] cellular device bro it's
like a random account like you don't
need to go
arguing with random twitter people and
calling blasting them out and calling
them [ __ ] like that's just
pretty psychotic bro
on a [ __ ] laptop or a cell phone hmm
the lithium batteries inside those where
do they get those oh they get those um
out there and they have to mine and then
destroy forest and murder animals
i'm not sure what's this woke take
but by the way this is the sum did you
grab this sack
you didn't crack you didn't grab this no
no i did not so this is the sound bite
where i was like oh we need this listen
to this forest and murder animals
just that okay
murder animals i'll pull it this account
that hasn't triggered has 92 followers
yeah exactly that's that's cute stuff
for you i'm gonna put this 92 follower
account on blast those um out there and
they have to mine and then destroy
forest and murder animals for it you
stupid [ __ ] everything you do in
society are i mean animals are displaced
i don't know what lithium mines he's
talking about there's a weird woke tape
right you're [ __ ] killing animals all
right when you're driving your car down
the road stupid [ __ ]
jesus
so
hateful wasn't he the one that ran over
a dog or something or made a joke about
running over yeah he ran over he wasn't
a joke he he killed a dog
yeah it wasn't a joke he wasn't a joke
no joke man i [ __ ] up
was it a deer or a dog
uh there's a gas in there they have to
[ __ ] mine that they have to pull that
out of the [ __ ] ground and guess what
dies
why are animals dying when we're mining
uh i mean he's probably right lithium
mining is very destructive no he's
talking about gasoline mining now oil
well why are animal why are we killing
like listen to this weird welcome on the
road stupid [ __ ] uh there's a gas in
there they have to [ __ ] mind that
they have to pull it out of the [ __ ]
ground guess what dies animals die and
that's a good soundbite too
i don't know when keemstar's world is
just he love he loves imagining animals
everywhere dying all right like dude the
the forests are being destroyed animals
are being died for you to just animals
are being dying society that you live in
so when you're sitting there [ __ ]
chirping right oh my god she murdered
rabbits for chairs
dumb people are like yeah she murdered
rabbits for chairs smart people are like
well pretty much everything you do in
your [ __ ] life you know you're
murdering animals for
stupid [ __ ] murderer
[Music]
he's so [ __ ]
he is the most toxic
can i give him a compliment though he
holds his camera so still every time
he's so triggered but he moves it like
he's shooting a tick tock every time
excellent camera discipline well he's
got a short stubby little hand that may
be easy
he doesn't have a joint in his hand he
has a short muscular powerful hand yeah
and yeah that's
can't say it's got a stubby hand
my body shaming him
a little bit star [ __ ] what about when
people say he looks like a gnome easy
was that body shaming
box me [ __ ]
anyway the whole story was pretty
interesting how it unfolded
uh but yeah there you have it anyway
enough about keem and uh trisha there's
just one more thing i mean i understand
i this this clip kind of contradicts
his stance about kill all animals
maybe it was just a moment you and the
dogs
i'm more than gay i'm
i'm bestiality
he like so he's
i don't get the connection he says i'm
not just gay
i'm bestiality hmm i don't think you can
be bestiality bestiality is an act that
you do not
right it's not a preference it's a verb
not a noun
also there's no connection between uh
homosexuality and bestiality by the way
right yeah those are maybe he provides
more same level
let's see
every full moon
i just get sprung
it was the reflex
maybe not
okay
well anyway here let's before we go to
break
let's watch this video was sent to me
this video is going viral it says new
hip hop uh superstar
aim b bobby b bobby chin up high don't
want to watch this this has been making
the rounds 180 000 this is a new rapper
she just hit the streets or just hit the
you know she only has three videos from
two months ago she dropped her debut
single and then this one's a week ago
three super easy keto recipes
to have fun with is that one also a song
no
no it's just a cooking video interesting
well people are torn on this it's kind
of like island boys so you tell me what
you think like does it slap
or does it
sloop
slapper slew
[Music]
with my chin up
you think i'm ugly i don't care you
think i'm dumb i don't care
i don't
[Music]
people always hating but the more they
hate the more i work everybody say
they're lit but all they do is showing
[ __ ] in my street like the slaves
[ __ ] always kiss my feet stay out of
my way you [ __ ] i can do what you fake
as me they thought that i had stopped it
was over i ain't dropped [ __ ] i had my
plans out here i'm only just at my start
you will have to oh
make me [ __ ] stop i was already dead
again you can't hurt me
[Music]
did i kind of think it slaps
um
[Music]
[Music]
can you imagine how good this would be
if you had it all memorized
i can memorize it i would i would
absolutely memorize
you want to do it you want to take the
parts of it i don't want to do a
performance of it i would love to
memorize it
and then i'll listen to it together and
we all sing it all together i think
olivia is proposing a recreation of this
music video
yeah i know what our off the rails
episode uh segment is going to be next
week cold open cold open
maybe we all take a birthday we need to
take a
can you order this uh this thank you
chinese food takeout uh shirt tank top
yeah
i don't know
it kind of slaps it really does
i'm calling it
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i hear my daddy's breath that's kind of
dark
no i don't know that's what she said
okay wait wait here maybe we have closed
caps yeah let's close captioning
all i get is music that's it they
deciphered the craziest [ __ ] ever and
somehow they're just dropping the ball
and this is gonna happen oh we have the
lyrics let's go chin up high genius okay
let's see
um
let's see party
till i die [ __ ] them all [ __ ] bye
ain't scared of death but i fear damn is
dead as breath
fear
damn damn damn dan's breath
i fear damn is dead as breath it's kind
of a pull damage breath all the drugs in
your face so here we go
[Music]
all the [ __ ] you said made you look like
a little [ __ ] flat head your opinion
[ __ ] [ __ ] that what do i think of you
how i
[Music]
i mean if the island boys can go
viral this is more deserving this is i'm
i'm not kidding
here's the line to the torque like it's
my death day on this earth pack will be
too oh no stop it
that's that was one of the top comments
that i post about it oh the top comment
is take it twerk like it's my last day
and there's poc will be
turning in his grave
tupac is down with this [ __ ] this is
what hip-hop is
[Music]
[Music]
watch this
dollar
rain
green screen
i bet it's the first oh yeah
this one you think
it looks a little oh maybe
yeah that might be it
[Laughter]
royalty free audio jungle
adios
[Music]
[Music]
like actually for real
like obviously it's goofy but also kind
of a bop like i mean i would
i go ahead dan
i mean i'll never listen to this again
that's what you're asking like it's not
going on the playlist no no sorry i
think it's an industry plant
no one comes up no one comes up with
this kind of production quality without
any videos beforehand right she has
backing of some big corporation
that is a huge budget video i think you
might be right about that well she
already has merch too
china pie party till i die i'm curious
what our water cooking tips are all
about interestingly um
this is basically on par with drake
merch so
yeah i love how it's stretched like
this is such a wild uh blank with the
chest all pumped out
damn it's all just chin up hi
party till i die all right so anyway
this is just a video i wanted to share
with you guys you know thank you bob
let's take a vote
bob dan
olivia bob
a.b certified bob
zach bob
and
try also bob
dan the soul hater
y'all are lying
i am yeah oh so so ian gives it i think
it's a bop i don't know i never cooked
that fire
farty till i die
i think i think the the the beat and the
music the instrumentation is definitely
a lot better than the vocals but having
said that i still think it's a bop
all right well shout out to um
to aim
all right let's throw it to a commercial
and when we come back we have an
exclusive interview
with carlos what's his let's say
carlos matos
you guys remember him from big connect
fame
you know hit him with the sound bite
let's let's let's hit let's introduce
here let me just show you guys just in
case you may not know what
this guy
yeah so we talked to him previously
[Music]
[Applause]
and um
you know he was he took place in this
great bit connect
[Applause]
and we talked to him recently uh
somewhat recently and
he was into i don't know he was doing
his thing but he recently reached out to
us via email he's launching a huge nft
project with some people he met
and i'm just super excited to hear about
it you know he's coming off big connect
which was you know a dark chapter in
crypto
do and history um i'm just curious how
he
how's he gonna frame this right he's
back in the crypto space he's back he's
back he's back on the blockchain and
this time he's not getting scammed he's
well i guess we'll find out no yeah
chris he said he pledged to us last time
he's out on the scams he's smart he
learned his lesson right
well i guess we'll find out
all right i'm very much looking forward
to that call stay tuned we'll be right
back with carlos time to take a short
break thank you to curology
i love curology it has put my
face care routine back on the table
i bailed on trying to take care of my
face because i just hated trying to
figure out what products to use in what
order you know and curology makes it
easy
and they do it with the help of a
licensed dermatology provider
so these are professionals giving you
professional products this is how it
works
they customize a prescription formula
with three active ingredients picked for
you to help tackle your skin care needs
whether that may be trying to take
control of acne or if acne is no longer
your top skin concern maybe it's fine
lines dark spots occasional breakouts or
clogged pores all you got to do is start
by answering some questions about
uh
your skin and if it's a good fit then
cure algae will match you with a
licensed dermatology provider who will
get to know your skin and subject to
consultation you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your door so yeah i answered
a bunch of questions i sent them
pictures of my skin
and they
formulated the perfect you know cream
for me
and i've got three products i do the
cleansing
which is super soft it doesn't feel like
it destroys my skin after the cleanse i
put on the dermatology provider
uh cream that they shipped out to me and
then i moisturized it's that easy my
skin just feels great feels healthy
i love it i recommend it you can start
your curology journey just like i did
with a free 30-day trial at curology.com
h3 and if prescribed you pay just five
bucks for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash h3 to unlock your free
30-day trial thank you
thank you curology
all right here we go
cooler weather makes it easier to miss
signs of dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body
properly hydrated
introducing liquid iv
we love liquid iv in fact
we drink it all the time and here's dan
proving to you
what flavor is that the hydration uh
it's um hydration multiplier
and this one's strawberry and tastes
really good actually oh you got
strawberry flavors that's like a new
flavor let's go
yeah so liquid iv it's a pack you mix it
in water they've got all these different
types they've got like uh
energy with caffeine they've got an
immune boost with a bunch of vitamin c
kind of they got the hydration formula
uh hydrated baby
you know in the morning before a workout
when you're running
any of these times even to cure a
hangover
it's loaded with all those uh
all that good stuff you know
vitamins electrolytes
exactly vitamins electrolytes it's got
the whole freaking chabang they've got
lemon lime strawberry watermelon passion
fruit guava pina colada
or immune support and tangerine
here's the deal
it hydrates faster than water alone
contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and as much
potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
it has no artificial flavors or
preservatives and it's got less sugar
than an apple it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan no gluten no
dairy no soy
[Music]
you know
we love them i love liquid iv sometimes
i don't want your coffee in the morning
just [ __ ] your stomach up it's heavy
and liquid iv gives you that boost but
it's more wholesome it's more hydrating
grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you can get 25
percent off when you go to liquidive.com
and use the code h3o check out that's 25
off anything you order when you get
better hydration today
when using the promo code h3 at the
liquid iv.com
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up can you hear me
no his audio's not connected
garlows
yeah so i'll just talk i'll just set it
up so yeah carlos reached out to us
he has a huge opportunity i don't know
if you can hear me or not or if he's
talking to someone else uh his audio his
audio is not connected he's talking to
somebody or any of this so carlos
reached out to us he has a huge
opportunity
he promises he's not he's no longer
scamming uh and crypto right after the
big connect thing i think he just
connected but he's now got a huge
opportunity in nfts he emailed us he's
super excited to bring us this
opportunity today
we are so excited
now i think he can hear me but i can't
hear him
or i don't know if he can hear you and
you're me oh i can hear you carlos
what's going on in that room what are
you guys scheming on in there
uh yeah i am going to introduce you to
this amazing uh you know team that i'm
working with that i'm so proud i
actually
uh love these guys like if they were my
brothers
uh in fact they are my brothers
literally literally blood relative
actually you're not they are not blood
relative but we are like you know like
sold relatives i will say
and this is max here maxinellian is an
amazing guy he's the ceo of the company
and we got alex goldberg as well and we
got amos as well come on guys let them
see your faces oh yeah
show your faces so when the fbi does a
follow-up let's get a good job let's get
a good look at those faces guys
absolutely yeah you gotta you know
they gotta know exactly who we are we're
ready we're ready
okay what's going on uh carlos you
reached out to us in email
you have an exciting is so exciting
opportunity and nfts
what's going on what do you got for us
well this this is about this is about
redemption
this is about me
uh one more time
saying to all of those people out there
that got screwed by the
experience of you know bit connect yeah
that
i i was not a mastermind i was not
part
of that
you know that scheme that i was just an
investor who was really excited who
found myself on top of the world
and then later on we realized that
i have in in fact been taken advantage
by this these people who were
masterminding and using
my name and using my speech
uh you know to their advantage so so
we're returning so we're turning a new
leaf we're taking one last ride
absolutely and by by now
um
having this
opportunity to work with this creative
minds that i have right here this
amazing
team
um i'm able to provide to the world
um a way for them to hold in their hands
a piece of history a piece of the
cryptocurrency proportion because what i
truly
understand
that it was that this not it was this
was not really about bit connect
this was about
the cryptocurrency movement the
cryptocurrency
revolution and what an amazing way for
me to tell people listen go ahead out
there and take a piece
of this um incredible history so what is
it
what are we selling
here i'm going to i'm going to actually
introduce you to max and max is going to
touch base on some of the things that
we're doing um
guys listen him up okay yeah
max basically max
max
how did you get hooked up with carlos
what's going on yeah how did you guys
meet
so amos actually uh
had been in contact with your face
for a while and uh you know it turns out
you know carlos
lives in new york as well and you know
we synced up and
are you guys like crypto bros is that
what kind of the this would you consider
yeah yeah are you guys how you doing
with the crypto market you guys doing
good killing it
well we're doing good you know i i
recently did i i originally had an
exciting time because i was one of the
sellers of an ether rock i got in that
whole craze and i got a little news
coverage because of that i bought in at
90 and i sold a lot of my assets for old
school ft so what is this nft project
you guys are doing but we're you know
let me we're we're getting too off off
topic here so um
basically the original video was
a moment in an iconic moment in crypto
history
that
is on the same level as like the doge
meme and and the importance of that that
is the space so you know what we're
doing is is we're taking each moment
from that video all 28 moments from that
original video and
releasing them as nfts which are all
going to be auctioned off
on
uh
you know once they're made in contract
they can be auctioned on open c zora let
me ask you
i don't believe that carlos owns the
rights to that video am i wrong how are
you guys licensing that
um the the actual person in that video
is
me
yeah
yeah but probably by but but whoever
took the video probably owns the
the license to the work right that's how
that works
that is interesting but at the same time
it's like it's called
physics they're exploring they're
exploring who i am and they did it
without
my consent so well it goes both did you
right did you not you didn't send a
consent form to be there or anything
carlos no
no there is no consent form and so we
also edited the video and made it our
own so we chopped it all up basically
similar to what you do ethan um and kind
of comment on the video clips like so
it's just it's just like pieces of the
video it's not like the actual full
video it's only like specific moments
that we've
kind of edited ourselves in premiere so
but
basically because you guys don't have
the exclusive rights to this footage
i could launch the same nfts
i could launch the same nfts and compete
with you guys do you think maybe we
could
any anybody could actually go ahead and
do that but there is one difference we
should do that ethan
what's the difference the difference is
that you are you're carlos
is that yeah i am the living meme
yeah who is involved with this
and i'm the one that's doing it
along with my team here
interesting
they have
you guys have carlos that's the magic
sauce
so how much nfts are we looking at here
say what 28 nfts
which is each clip from the um
from the video you know
my ideas with this space are just
extremely simple extremely transparent
you know like just keep it small like i
would don't want to do a crazy nft
project don't try to usurp cash from all
these people like
i know plenty of people in the space
that like to buy spend an enormous
amount of money on rocks and other memes
just through having to eat the rock i've
met those kinds of people right so
doing something where it's really simple
and just being able to like remember
this moment like grail in time the
important part is that this is carlos
coming out saying this is my nft nfts
for my moment right do you think
possibly you you compared carlos moment
to like the doge face as an internet as
a moment in crypto history
but i think on on one hand um
it's also a dark moment in crypto
history
when there was a massive you know
uh fraud that took place and a lot of
people lost their money which is a
problem
going on in the crypto world right now
you see lots of rug pulls and crypto
schemes and stuff
so
are you possibly um tokenizing the wrong
moment to make that uh to make that
claim to the world let me say something
now let me let me let me address that
because that was a really good
good
thing that he said right there
um
i i love first of all i love
that question let me address it
um let's think about
so many of us that have gone through
life
looking to better ourselves looking to
better the world
and how many times have we gone
and
don't deal
that turn out to be failures
that we went in with the very best
intentions
that we wouldn't because we really felt
that we were going to help other people
that we're going to be able to change
the world and we went with all our
hearts and and with all our souls trying
to do that but then later we found out
that that was not the case
so because of that you're going to just
put yourself in a dark room and say to
yourself you know what i'm never going
to do anything else that's it i'm done
this is part of you know the worst thing
in the world therefore i am not moving
anymore you know what i am really going
to shoot myself with me
actually carlos i'm not blaming you i'm
just talking about no no no no wait wait
wait wait wait no excuse me i mean i
mean that come on
i'm just talking about the big connect
phenomenon itself
i'm talking about in moment history in
which i actually went into something
with all of the intention to be able to
improve myself and improve and improve
others by letting them know that this
was something amazing because what i saw
in it was the actual
amazing potential of cryptocurrencies
that was what i saw in bitcoin and when
i was saying that the world is not
anymore the way it used to be
no no no guess what it is not the world
it used to be
assassin happy indeed changed the world
so i don't really think that i am taking
it the way you're saying that's not a
dark moment in my life
fair enough beautiful okay
that's great no that's a great ant
that's a great response how about what
are the what are these going to start
out what's the starting bid going to be
starting out on these
start zero starting at zero baby for
free
zero no like basically people are going
to we're going to market this to the
right people people are going to want to
auction these things off we're going to
release one tomorrow that's so exciting
at the end of nft nyc and it's going to
be the clip of him saying i'm i'm carlos
matas i'm from new york city new york
you know the idea is that
you know this is an opportunity for
carlos to win off the fact that people
have been using his memes you know all
this stuff for years um one of you guys
sent us this video can you see it
yeah that was me
yeah so you guys want to just there's
just a little clip of carlos from last
night
shirtless
um
you guys want to give a little backstory
here what was that why did you guys send
us this
so angus brought him to the polygon
party
last night what is the polygon
polygon is a layer two ethereum scaling
solution they had a party somewhere
always the life of the party carlos
yeah so so
you were a hit huh why did why did why
send us this one in particular well
there's a bunch no that i sent to you
guys a whole drive of videos uh there's
actually some really way more funny ones
in there
this one this is actually the one that
stuck out to me
let me tell you let me tell you guys
um
you know so many people that are being
that are benefiting from
you know the political network and you
know i give a very big shout out to them
i mean they're doing amazing work i love
it
this whole project was actually inspired
by h3h3 because i
like many other people did not know
carlos wasn't a part of this until i saw
the h3h3 interview
with carlos and i like learned who he
actually was an aba therapist a father
who is basically saved multiple children
of his from autism
and uh from them bumping their head on
the wall i didn't know that was who
carlos was i thought he was a part of
the big connect scandal and you learned
that from our interview
yeah no well yeah we we talked we did
learn a lot about carlos that's true
yeah
so that actually inspired me to go find
carlos and make this
you guys created the bit redemption yeah
i mean
this is well you know carlos was carlos
was m.i.a we were looking for him he was
like looking for uh
what's that chess kid everyone was
looking for
there's a chess kid everyone was looking
for finding
oh [ __ ] it you're the chess kid carlos
we were looking for you
but we found you it sounds like you're
doing well you got hooked up with some
good dudes out here
um
and it looks like you're having fun out
there at polygon
absolutely
how'd you end up with your shirt off
hey um
it was one of those guys and you know he
went up
he took his shirt off i said okay well
if you're going to be challenging me
then [ __ ] you i'm going to challenge you
too
so yeah yeah he took his shirt off and i
said okay what's going on
i didn't want to i didn't want a guy to
be showing you know he's he's cutting
and what can i ask
you said carlos saved
you said carlos saved multiple kids from
autism do you want to explain what that
means
uh yes uh autism is really an umbrella
of behaviors
and
if you are under the umbrella of
behaviors you're considered to be
autistic
but as time goes by if
you're able to
change those behaviors
well i mean carlos is an expert he's an
aba therapist and
definitely has a vast amount of
knowledge on says i might have misword
what i said but he's helped
stop certain habits from his children
who actually grew up with autism
right okay so when you
yeah but what you say when you say when
you say
sorry
you're picking up on you know
word
but you know the actual sorry
the actual message is that i have been
able to help children with autism okay
you didn't you didn't
to be able to help with their behaviors
that's what he meant he didn't care
no i don't you know it's not some it's
something that you that they actually
certain behaviors they have and they
need to be able to learn how to stop and
eradicate those behaviors that's it i
got it no that's that's awesome
so this is really exciting i you know
what's what's the what's the schedule
like for you guys with the the rollout
of this
rollout hasn't even been really
scheduled other than that we're
releasing the first one tomorrow okay
and the way
where it currently stands is they can
sit there and they can sit there in the
in the wallet you know people can see
them oh you already minted them
yeah well we're not we're actually going
to finish the minting tonight and then
we're going to in preparation for the
event tomorrow we're going to mint out
all 28. well give up give us a plug
where can we where can we bid on these
either zoro open c i'm talking to
uh some people about doing a fractional
or a party bed where essentially a bunch
of people can all
reduction.com there is a website too bit
redemption.com where people can
um go ahead and see the actual auction
happening
right there that you know
it's gonna start happening on thursday
start you know at the end of thursday
from four to seven that's when we're
gonna start launching it'll it'll it'll
get better over time there was a guy who
wanted carlos to speak at the you know
the new ftx arena
let's look at the website bit redemption
this is it
yeah awesome it seems to be
oh this is awesome let's take a look
okay so so i can see what the nft
actually looks like is this one here
hey hey hey so this is gonna probably
gonna be a big one right well this
website's crazy
ellen how do i watch one
it just says hey hey hey
exactly
oh i can't watch it
so is it just an image are you guys just
selling the
it's image the the videos we're playing
before oh really yeah on my computer
maybe it's a
a browser thing going on
we did all we did do all 20 i think we
took through all 28 in there so
but yeah that's like we just put that in
last night you know yeah
the idea is that look let's keep it
simple let's keep it jenny let's keep it
authentic look at all the wallet
addresses see what's going on
you know
um yeah i just want to see
in there yeah i want to buy it i
definitely want to buy one
um
i just want to take a look at one of
these videos so is this one of the nfts
that says
metamorphosis is
that so that's that's the company so why
would someone want to buy an image of
metamorphosis i s
i was not it's not an nft i think
oh that one's not an nft
that's our logo our company
yeah so why would someone want to buy
the logo to your company because you
guys own it right so why would you want
to stop that's not that's not an nfc
it's just uh we'll take it we'll take it
off
it was just something that that threw
and it must have been a news
realistically look we're not gonna
so are you guys selling this one or not
no
i mean
if i wasn't right or somebody wants to
buy it oh so you guys are minting this
this isn't related to carlos i'm just
confused
no you're not just
it's just it's just a plug our name oh
is this a sketch of carlos is that how
it's related or no that's a
butterfly appears to be a butterfly of
something oh okay
yeah metamorphosis i think it's kind of
the idea of um
you know changing
right becoming involved in the metaverse
it
um here i'm just trying to see some
other ones here here this one's
interesting oh so this is so this one's
on sale
now
i'm trying to click it's the only one
that shows up here okay this isn't the
only one that shows it's the only one
okay
so like let's wait for a new one
here's one coming up
wait redemption.com just reload the site
maybe just reload it oh here's a new one
wait here's a new one
so is this one for sale
i guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it
let's see well here i just reloaded so
let's grab some other nfts
oh my god there's so many
here's one right here
so you're gonna share
i can't click it no damn oh here it is
thank you for the plug so is this one of
the nfts because this is the one that
showed up
here let me reload the site maybe if i
open a different browser
hey let me start let me do like an
incognito browser is that a good idea
yeah
how do i open incognito in this uh what
is this firefox do you guys know how to
open it do it incognito on firefox
ctrl shift b
control
shift b
lp control shift p
oh
[ __ ]
can you guys
just troubleshoot this with me
yeah so how do i do the um
what the heck is going on there
can you share our screen okay so control
control what how do i open the um
what's the command
ctrl shift e
command command shift p that's what i'm
titting
well maybe it's controlled i i was
because it's a mac i thought maybe it
would be command yeah it's not doing
anything
well that should open a new i should
just reopen it because the website's
working on our browsers it is okay so
hold on hold on hold on
so here's the one i'm seeing
wait no but for real damn why why can't
i open up
hang on guys you were asking if in
firefox it looks like you're using
chrome my dude well then why isn't it
showing me
without you
that literally is an old there must be
an older
click the three click the three little
buttons on the top right
i can't see [ __ ] it's okay okay i
couldn't see it that's why yeah and then
new incognito tab there oh no it's a
it's a it's not it's it's a control n
because it's chrome not firefox
okay okay yeah i use firefox all right
let's go ahead with this one so now
we're going back to bit redemption
all right
so there's no audio right
i think there will be tomorrow when we
do the live auction
so this is also going to be the
auctioneer i don't think i i don't think
it's i mean what
volume on the site i mean the videos are
going to be stored does the nft have
audio
yeah yeah well oh well okay good
no i mean it's with nfts it's
interesting right because it's like
you're storing pretty big files on the
blockchain
uh when you're uploading them to things
like openc or zorra
for example this specific um bitcoin
that you or well nft you guys are
selling so i'm assuming you guys got
like permission from everyone in the
background right to sell their their
faces
absolutely not no
right
because by the same logic you have
carlos's face we also have their face
you know like there's many cases and
examples of this in the nft space if you
look at the price of nakamoto pepes for
example versus whoa this shit's crazy
bro okay sorry go ahead you'll you'll
see like
people in in crypto like like
the copyrights of off-chain activity
don't really translate to on-chain
kind of the
the code or the stigmas or guidelines
yeah you're saying the laws haven't kind
of made it there yet
yeah well it's really like people
that are in crypto they
they they look at the ether ether scan
they look at the on-chain activity and
that's what they they trust is this law
important in a morality matt fury was
the original artist the pepe me for
example but the guy who created the rare
pepe cards on counterparty you know
those things are still selling for
what they sold for i think like a
million or 500 000 at sotheby's carlos
do you know who this lady is right here
you're basically just buying the coat
like that but it's not really even a
picture it's just like code it just
resources to a picture wait who's this
lady
was she one of the scammers no but i'm
just saying like you're selling a image
with her face on it
we're auctioning
yeah
oh there's a is there a difference
between auctioning and selling
i don't know i'm asking because you
corrected me i don't know the difference
no i didn't know it
is there a difference between auctioning
and selling no i just i was
we're just like releasing an auction
sorry we're not putting a price on it
yet right right right right okay okay
so
yeah i mean this is really exciting
stuff
hold on let me just so i i love all the
questions that you're raising and all
the things well you know i'm just i'm
i'm just uh
so you guys have anything you want to
say
you guys want to say anything in short
uh bit redemption obviously is work so
people are going to buy it on rip
redemption
or zoro philippines design
could do it on the website could just
integrate it embed it into the site
okay
so should people go to bit redemption to
buy it or no i'm where should people go
oh yeah they'll go to bit
change
whether it's a link to the auction page
or it's embedded within the site
no it's not it's not too big of a deal
the the matter of the fact is this is
carlos's moment the carlos is going to
be pushing
it doesn't we don't need like fireworks
and craziness but you know the just the
integrity and that carlos is is
gaining from the fact that he has become
this grand internet meme on a large
scale you know why not right people have
done this with other things in the past
and what's funny about this to me is i
think we're going to guarantee more
money than quentin tarantino's nft
collection now maybe that's crazy but
when i s when when you're in crypto
space and you're in crypto land with
people who do crypto money
this kind of stuff makes a lot more
sense buying rocks for a million dollars
buying
but i like the art of nothing like
that is within the tunes of kind of like
the space that we're in and that's why i
think it's such an exciting project more
than i would be excited about doing it
with some big celebrity like this allows
me to cut to the core of like
the target market here the people
actually well i'm interested i'll be
fine
carlos how are you feeling about
everything are you excited are you
excited about the launch tomorrow
yeah i believe that
this is uh part of the redemption
and
it's exciting because it gives me a way
for me to
uh capture a piece of history
how i felt at that point in time
about cryptocurrency coming into the
cryptocurrency world
like
discovering something that i believe
that could change the world
all right so everybody head on over to
bit redemption
where
you can bid on this
nfc
it's showing the logo again
yeah
so is this one launching tomorrow it's
not that one it's it's the ones of
carlos wait is this one launching
tomorrow
at this point at this point we're going
to have to launch it now
no not
all right guys well i'm really excited
i love it i'm glad carlos is getting an
opportunity to you know
get get some guacamole out of this thing
and uh i actually think people are gonna
be interested and you guys are gonna
make a lot of money so
just be careful have you guys consulted
a lawyer at all on any of this stuff
i actually do have a lawyer i mean i
understand that there's a certain
laws the big concern was
fractionalization
so when you when you fractionalize an
nft you're looking at things like
you're you're creating creating a
security right but doge meme got
fractionalized it went up to like a 100
million evaluation they did it
through this thing pleaser doubt did it
right which is which is
they're
sort of
in this gray area of the law and stuff
whereas if a company did that they would
get pressed by the sec for
securities rights like that yeah
you'd want to do it and if if we were
going to do it we basically would want
to have no piece of it like we're not
selling
if there's a carlos you know matos
coin
carlos wouldn't it be i'm sorry i'm
sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry to bring it here but carlos
wouldn't it be ironic if you guys got in
trouble for this
no i i mean
life is about taking risks and
and if you know you go out there and you
find something
and you take you you do it with your the
very best intention that you want
and you're going to get into risk
then
that i think that no but it is ironic
because it's called the redemption arc
it'd be funny if you guys got in legal
trouble for this yeah
yeah that would be hilarious why would
a dark sense of humor or just a sense of
humor in general right but hopefully
they have a sense of humor if when the
judge sent it to you guys
you know hopefully defense hopefully the
fans have a sense of humor
for sure
well thank you guys
i'll be following we'll you know we'll
check in on friday we do a live show so
we'll be sure to check in on friday i'm
super excited i might even make a bid
myself
and uh i'm just i'm really happy about
this
i'm excited and uh i look forward to
seeing more from you guys
thank you thank you guys so much all
right thank you thanks for calling in
it's always nice to hear from you carlos
and to see you nice to meet you guys the
crypto bros
obviously
gonna be seeing lots of you guys in the
future
and hopefully not like uh
you know
not like uh wall street journal yeah i
know
hopefully not in like uh case study more
just you know headlines and stuff like
that right
yeah well if we actually start looking
at cryptocurrency there would be
i don't know how many other crypto i
mean how many i don't know how many
other case stories
they're going to be there because
cryptocurrency is full of them yeah for
sure
for sure
all right guys you take care it was
awesome chatting with you all had a lot
of uh learned a lot had fun we'll be
checking on a friday
can't wait
thank you guys
well that was uh
i'm super excited i am so excited
it seems like he's in good hands
uh yeah
definitely by the way he was saying that
uh his one of the dudes said that carlos
uh
what did he say he said uh carlos saves
kids from autism so
i just was afraid it would be like one
of these people you're like his favorite
youtuber oh dude thanks bro thank you so
much man i appreciate that a lot
for real man
it's a shame you can't be here ready do
you know why he's not here um just
couldn't come he has asperger's like
autism
so it wouldn't have been very good for
him to come
all right well i mean hopefully you get
well soon and
i'll see you guys
yeah so it's not a get better soon
situation we
love our fans with autism
well i'm actually really excited to see
how the launch goes on friday i am very
excited to see how this goes yeah
i think it's going to be a
big hit
all right well
awesome
oh
well interesting
fascinating stuff you know what's
fascinating not the global climate
conference
because joe biden fell the [ __ ] asleep
at it straight up
look at that segway sleepy joe this was
awesome and i mean listen
i voted for joe
because trump's obviously psychotic
[ __ ] i mean what can what bad can't
you say about donald trump
but
this is what we get man our paul our
politicians are all old as [ __ ] and
listen i'm not
i i don't want to sound like an aegis or
something but like
he's almost 80 years old and you know
most people are retired by then
you retire what 65 that's when you start
getting social security
you know
i mean you don't see people really
working uh at sea i i don't know it just
seems like a lot i mean this is what i
expect
for my eight-year-old
world leader it's one of the most
important meetings in history
we are in a climate crisis
is she sleeping too yeah it looks like
she's sleeping dude everyone's just
passed the [ __ ] out there that shows you
how important the whole climate change
thing is to these guys you know
i was listening to uh
i was listening to the dailies report on
it and it just seems like such a [ __ ]
virtual signaling non-committal [ __ ]
like nobody's doing anything
the planet is dying
your bison wake up
literally
and you know our leaders are sleeping
this woman is sleeping i think you're
right
she just passed the [ __ ] out
he's like sir uh you need to wake the
[ __ ] up i'm pretending like i'm doing
something but uh
and i mean trump is old as [ __ ] too it's
not just you know him
i mean trump is like in his late 70s as
well right
he's [ __ ] gassed the [ __ ] up on him
phantom means though he's not falling
asleep yeah somehow he does seem a
little more alive
joel biden
i mean to be fair he just took a flight
over international flight
yeah that's the job dude
that's why you kind of gotta have a
little
step exactly oh god i miss it
i would love to see joe biden
send an email like my mom that should be
a prerequisite
for the job
you need to be able to seamlessly send
it send an attachment just put an
attachment and send an email if you
can't do that in less than 30 seconds
you're unqualified
um there's also big news
um
no leftovers this week so we gotta we
gotta get this out of our system right
now
i think he's even getting the sleep out
of his eyes man he took like a good long
snooze there he wiped him dressed out
yeah dude
and
you know tucker tucker carlson went on a
whole joe bite and there's a new
conspiracy here too guys you're gonna
love
uh did you guys know that joe biden is
turning orange
well back in january liberals around the
world celebrated the white house was no
longer occupied by an orange president
now a lot of viewers of this show have
noticed something
joe biden is turning orange oh dude are
you one to speak this guy is like
straight up dipped in or in cheeto sauce
look at tucker that dude's more orange
than anyone
orange gate
love this is the discourse honor this is
the most popular show new show in the
country this is the national discourse
does this surprise you i love american
politics yeah
two orange man two orange men debating
who's more orange that's [ __ ] awesome
yeah this is hard-hitting stuff
look at the pictures in other words the
orange man is back
what's happening here
what's happening here
is it the water is it something else we
don't know we're going to stay on that
what the story was that dude
what the [ __ ] orange man bad well this
guy's orange i don't think joe biden
does spray tan stacker i think that was
the whole joke
i'm pretty sure it's just orange lights
oh yeah i mean we just watched that clip
of him falling asleep he didn't look
that orange there so i'm assuming it's
you people say trump was orange orange
bad
here's a photo of biden
biden orange
checkmate orange badge
bite in orange
checkmate liberal hypocrites yeah violet
you're turning violet violet
interesting paul willy wonka therefore i
rest my case to the american people
that's good stuff
you know who else is orange
who garfield
checkmate america no such thing as a
coincidence
you know who else
send a photo
you know who else is orange
oh i know who else
[Music]
oranges
that's not what i was going to say
centipedes is pretty orange
sent photos
carlos is orange
i think he's actually
waiting
i mean he actually is a darker
complexioned man so right
all right so it i mean garfield is an
orange cat
right that's true
why are we describing
orange right czech mate atheists
there is a god
that's proof of god
you know who else is orange
this ginger [ __ ]
isn't he ginger
ryan cavanaugh is a ginger
authentic signed orange from keemstar
what
forty five thousand dollars
this orange rabbit hole has no bottom
trisha paytas is orange
that is orange spirit
wait what color hold on what color is
copeland kenneth copeland oh let me look
that up
kenneth
copeland color
hmm
well wait hold on
uh he's not orange he's a white yeah
he's not hey come on
well oh hold on here wait wait hold on
look at this one yep
wait wait wait you're gonna this is
gonna blow your [ __ ] mind dude
that's an orange man that's an orange
that's an orange man who's tried to make
himself more white cover the truth
do you see it
i do you know who else is orange
well this is more dark than orange so
nice try
that's just straight up i mean
that's just a good ass tan right there
dude
that's just a good ass tan my friends
wow
this is compelling stuff
wait he needs i someone needs to send
this to tucker i mean this is
interesting reporting for the national
discourse
is it the water or is it nothing we
don't know we're going to stay on that
story
yeah you stay on that tucker
that's amazing
our country's so [ __ ] bro yep
you know it's like why even bother
trying i'm done trying bro
i need to move in with post malone in a
bomb shelter and you thon
we can turn the ace family house into a
into a doomsday compound once we buy
that oh doomsday preppers
[ __ ] yeah you think so you think we
could make that in tune we could make it
work we could grow our own like
foliage
oh speaking of how little people care
about this climate summit here's [ __ ]
wolf blitzer of cnn
again nobody gives a [ __ ] this
[ __ ] flew to scotland
where he tweeted i'm flew to edinburgh
edinburgh edinburgh
how's it been bird there's no oh because
it's well that's just how it's
pronounced that's how they do it out
there huh
i'm sure i'm actually
scottish fans i apologize i probably
didn't say it quite right either but it
didn't put it up
exactly
he's flown out to edinburgh in scotland
where 20 000 world leaders and delegates
have gathered
for the climate summit
well this [ __ ] idiot is in the wrong
city
he's straight up set up this is wolf
blitzer now and love just because you
don't know this is a huge political
commentator one of the most famous faces
in political commentary wolf blitzer
he's in the wrong place my dudes
epic
it was it was actually in uh
glasgow
glasgow of scotland approximately 50
miles away from where he is
and he and this tweet's still up by the
way i mean well i saw some people giving
some explanations that i guess the
delegation originally flew
there and then
took buses to glasgow or something it it
doesn't really matter what the
explanation why is he reporting there
yeah and what do you mean they flew in
because the airports are that's like
saying there's a conference in las vegas
i'm here in la where some people arrive
right i don't it doesn't make any sense
i don't know it's funny he's in the
wrong city yes and i mean the photo is
even better because there's no one there
like the fact that it's an iconic
yeah he tweeted a picture of him with
the historic castle
yeah
miles away from the actual conference
i'd rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled yeah nobody cares nobody's doing
anything
they all make these i was listening to
the story they go
well they we've pledged to um stop
deforestation brazil pledged to stop
deforestation um
by the year 30 30. we're like okay great
they're like but we had this conference
in 2010 and they made the same pledge to
be done by now and deforestation has
gone up since then oops it's like okay
cool oops
nice
oh yeah he goes india has pledged to do
50
of their elec
of all of their uh power renewable uh by
2030 but nobody has any idea how that's
possible or how they could possibly do
it
well
indeed
i [ __ ] pledge to uh
never eat pizza again
yeah you know what's for lunch
exactly
yeah well they it's just it's pathetic
i just [ __ ] love this image so much
yeah it's awesome he's in the wrong
place you idiot you dumb [ __ ] just the
empty chair is what really gets me he's
like where is everybody
i sent some tweets the whole gang's here
about the situation it's pretty funny
some of the responses
uh let's see here here's some funny
responses to his tweets
uh united nations of the world this week
we meet in glasgow for the summit on
climate change wolf
i'm not going to [ __ ] glasgow i want
to see the castle
you know the one
[ __ ] glasgow
yeah
here's some other good ones
you know
it's just all
nobody gives a [ __ ]
that's the one i just read
uh here's another one
meanwhile the other 19 999 leaders
delegates and journalists are in glasgow
yeah exactly
[ __ ] dumbass
the top commoners should have gone to
glasgow
yeah you're in the wrong place and the
tweet is still love
[Laughter]
and
the account that tweeted that is a
glasses company sorry i think they're
kind of memeing on him like
you need glasses oh
interesting
you are here you are here everybody else
is here
so
damn
i can see you can make that mistake i
was looking at the map and it looks like
every place in scotland is actually
glasgow east glasgow
glasgow glasgow
east glasgow
that's true wait is this yeah so this is
glasgow glasgow glasgow
the sea is glasgow
all right enough for that
speaking of uh
how much do you know about cubanon love
over there in sweden
do you hear about them or not that much
well i just
like from the from our show that's all i
know
must be nice man what's like the
craziest political thing going on in
sweden right now
um well we changed to electric buses the
other week that was kind of crazy that's
awesome actually unlike unlike uh
america's looks like sweden actually
doing something
yeah well i doesn't like antifa
originated from sweden or something
done
that i'm not sure about i don't think so
okay
i don't know what i'm talking about
spain i think yeah well so apparently
there's a whole well the q anon
uh movement is still alive in fact they
were
today they believe that jfk
junior who died in a car crash many
years ago
they believe that jfk jr
will reappear out of hiding
to proclaim donald trump the king of
kings
isn't the king of kings like jesus
yeah the kunan
thing has like a very um like
fundamentalist christian under they
think donald trump is jesus it's like a
remake it's a 2020
kingdom i don't think that they think
that he's jesus i think in this
particular case these people thought
that jfk is sort of the the jesus-like
figure yeah so wherever they went to
where he was his dad was well jfk jr
okay jfk was assassinated
famously at the infamously at the grassy
knolls and they gathered their
grassy knoll the grassy there's only one
knoll okay conspiracy one or two knows
how many no's were there
some people say there wasn't an old lab
at all oh interesting
so here they are met where his father
was assassinated
to welcome his second coming
of jfk junior and this is a substantial
should be clear i i believe that they
actually thought both kennedys were
going to appear not just junior senior
as well the one that had his head blown
off yeah the theory is that trump is
still president and john
it's pretty well here let me read yeah
um
so they believe jfk jr faked his death
right the attendees believe that the
deceased son of assassinated president
will give a cue speech in which he will
ordain
donald trump as king of kings
sick
um
by what power
uh
q anon supporters uh how by what power
does jfk jr
delegate donald trump king
uh by nature of the fact that he's
died in a plane crash and is come back
to life i mean if that really happened i
i would probably you know believe what
he said
if he returned from the dead somehow
here they are uh q and on at the grass
you know in dallas they believe jfk is
coming back to make a speech yeah again
it's jfk not jfk junior well i i think
paul no no yeah it's the whole kennedy
clan is coming back is what these is
oswald gonna be there too
maybe look at all these [ __ ]
psychopaths bro this is what facebook
does to your brain yeah
this is there's like a legitimate amount
of people
come here
i read it was about a thousand to await
a dead man to crown donald trump king of
kings look at these people
they're waiting for this they believe it
it's happening
it's so scary it's scary
this is like total this isn't even like
the best conspiracy theories have like a
seed of truth this is just pure fantasy
yeah it's long since you know uh not not
to defend uh the q and on people but um
i was reading about this and this is one
of many splinter groups sin because like
the whole q on thing was like at any
moment
uh donald trump is going to arrest all
the pedophiles and satanists in
government and um
and you know execute them on national tv
and then when that didn't happen
and he's now out of office
like it's completely fractured into all
of these like subgroups that have
different beliefs about what's going to
happen so this is uh one subset of them
that um has taken to numerology uh in a
big way and through numerology they
think that they have proven that the
kennedy family is the direct descendants
of jesus christ oh for oh that's what it
is yeah and um and therefore uh that is
why
uh jfk senior is going to return from
the dead for seven days sort of like how
jesus rose from the dead for uh
was it seven days
i don't remember however long that
supposedly happened and um in that time
anoint
uh trump as the once and future king or
whatever and um and basically bring in
the end times
so what's weird is that the the kennedys
were like um
democrats liberal
icons
so the way it's weird how
that but here they are like the big ass
group look at all these [ __ ] people
these people are voters these people
have families these people are teachers
engaged brother these people are our
police
my spanish teacher from elementary
school posts q and on stuff [ __ ] yeah
dude there's so many cueing on people
this is not okay
that person taught me when my mind was
like moldable they taught your ass
they taught you something yeah they did
what do i have to unlearn probably so
much everything
what what kind of teacher spanish
spanish
interesting he probably doesn't like
mexicans if he's q anon right
yeah
well or immigrants i should say well i
assume he's just racist all around right
yeah i mean if you're queuing on it's
kind of a
it's kind of a catch-all of everything
bad in the human spirit
i mean i would actually argue that these
people even though it is largely
centered around trump these people
largely it's trump it's true i know but
but
um
it's sort of
it's sort of outside of politics at this
point again it's more of a religious
movement than it is a political movement
at this stage for the vast majority of
these people
and um
yeah i mean it's not a stretch to to
call it a cult uh because from what i
understand too um
spoiler alert i don't know if you were
saving this revelation but
jfk did not dude why'd you [ __ ] i was
getting to it bro why do you give the
ending away
i know everybody was probably on the
edge of their seat with that one but
yeah he did not show did any kennedy
caroline kennedy i don't think any
shriver maybe maurice shriver was she
there extended kennedy clan yeah
apparently apparently there's some
confusion about whatever
power jfk junior has to make
trump king of kings
because like even if he was alive and
never died jfk jr was never even elected
to office
right
yeah that that poses a problem but again
that's why i say it's outside of
politics because i don't i think the
more important part to them is the fact
that they have
they are direct blood descendants of
christ than
being president
look at all these people
no but they're all trump flags it's all
are people man
these are doing people doing your taxes
[ __ ] crazy so cool
there's a lot of them um [ __ ] awesome
keep going down the line
kept seeing videos of this
queuing on trump's reporter at dallas
who was waiting for jfk's dead son to
appear yeah it's jfk jr
against all about jfk junior claims that
trump will be back to the white house
soon
november 30th again this is not a
unified front and what i'm trying to
also all fake it yeah anyway there's a
lot of theories uh pouring into this
here's she's saying i have another piece
of information
november 30.
i believe that has passed oh that's
today so nothing happened
that would have been this early this
morning right yeah damn another lost
prophecy so they stayed there till
[ __ ] 1 30 and well let's see what she
says
two and a half hours after the concert
is flying
trump is going back
why
why
i don't think your information is good
praise jesus why is she holding a dog
that was kennedy's dog man it arose from
the dead oh wow
what are you what's your take on all
this love i mean is this interesting
yeah well i wish we could harness their
like their
like story making into like making an
anime or something because that sounds
kind of cool that would be a thick anime
like an old ruler comes back and like
likes a king
and something happens you know this
sounds kind of cool
sick manga jfk junior rides tonight at 1
30 a.m
someone here's another one you know
jfk junior's been dead 22 years
yeah even if it was true and he came
back it just didn't make sense to be
like yes i faked my death i'm here to
declare trump is king
it's like okay
by what power oh jesus
you know it doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense
some of them also believe that uh
you know
again that some want him to be king some
are he's just gonna be reinstated as
president my favorite is a lot of them
think that uh he's just he's going to be
reinstated as the 18th president of the
united states right i heard that there
because yeah some of them believe that
any u.s law passed after 1871 is
unconstitutional and therefore
uh
something about the civil war yeah was
unconstitutional
and on a technicality they're bringing
them back right it's taking over for
grant it's a it's a technicality
they got him on it
let's see um
here
uh here's a reporter gathering the night
before the resurrection kylie
these are all q and on people there's
currently a large crowd of what appears
to be q and on believers at a t
discovery plaza in downtown dallas
popular q a theory recently is that jfk
junior of the kennedy family making a
big announcement
big announcement i'm not [ __ ] dead 22
years
they're here waiting for a dead man to
give a speech
didn't happen okay let's go to the plot
let's go to the knoll right
here's another great facet so
part of the theory is that this q anon
guy
is jfk jr
okay he's a real guy a real q anon guy
and he will not confirm nor deny these
rumors right
so he's got he i think he's even gotten
to his head like i that's right i am jfk
jr
so this [ __ ] guy goes to q and on
rallies
this is him and he accepts it that's my
favorite part you know he wasn't like no
i'm not jfk junior he's like maybe i am
okay genius
or he just loves the attention look at
that no he but he listen this
here he is
the king
i love that he just looks like a king
nothing like jfk junior too like it's
like nothing what do you mean dude how
can you say that passing resemblance
how can you say that it's awesome
it looks more like gallagher than
[ __ ] jfk junior
uh you know it it doesn't appear that he
that vincent has ever
denied it in fact here he is tweeting
about it
vincent
uh he said
conquer darkness vincent fusa that's his
name and hashtag q
who killed jfk the very word secrecy is
yeah anyway he's basically
but what's interesting about vincent
fusa's twitter account
here's his last tweet notice the date
what's the date of his last tweet
[Laughter]
january 6th oh i wonder if anything
happened that [ __ ] is in jail
his last tweet was january 6 when the
capitol rides happen
how amazing is that so do you want to
you want another detail that really just
drives home how insane and out of
control this whole thing has become and
again why more than everything we just
watched
yes actually
so
on 8chan this was back in 2018
somebody directly asked them
is jfk junior alive and q the the the
person the anonymous person behind
this is q said no
they're like nah
literally and they were like look uh
this guy explains it in the tweet
despite the fact that q has directly and
clearly stated that jfk junior is not
alive uh alive kellyanne who was one of
the people at this thing uh will
continue to believe that jfk junior is
alive she justifies this because
disinformation is necessary yo they they
i love it they'll rationalize anything
whatever even from cue their guy he's
lying to us to do to
uh distract
right
crazy man it's awesome yeah here's
vincent fusa the guy that thinks jfk
tweeted out a picture of jfk
true north
it's awesome he's gotta be loving this
imagine if you're just a [ __ ] random
dude no he but i think he actually
starting to really believe he thinks
he's
like i am jfk junior maybe maybe
uh q anon supporters randomly began to
pick out random people they encountered
in dallas and started asking
if there were celebrities in disguise
who faked their death to avoid the deep
state
someone claimed robin williams was there
and another one claimed richard pryor
was there
i don't know what the connection that
any of these people have to any of this
no celebrities ever die that they're all
still alive and they're all uh
and they're all trump supporters the
cube follower made a 29 part
youtube series called jfk junior lives
the series is ongoing each video is
between
half an hour to an hour to two and a
half hours in length i didn't add up
that's gotta be around 60 hours of
content just on which we went to this
channel it's been deleted unfortunately
this content a lot of views though like
look at this like i'm just telling just
to tell you these are two hour [ __ ]
[ __ ] posts thirty thousand forty five
thousand thirty thousand thirty thousand
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah
yeah it's uh it's sad these people
look at this look at the times oh this
this is here's an extra it's a little
like it's awesome here's the cube for uh
researcher decoding the timestamp and id
of a post by cue
stamp it just happens to be the 23rd
hour right
and then the 14
you know the number 14 i read that as
seven and seven so a double 07 007 right
isn't that kind of like james bond that
is seven 007
so there's a little bit of a clue there
that's kind of how i read that the five
five the 55 is the five five we see that
a lot in the queue drops
i think that that means part of it part
of the meaning of that is just you know
i hear you i see you i'm understanding
the comms okay but get this look at the
id
17 there's our queue again and look at
this
letter of the alphabet like three
exclamation points like q
and a there it is right how the [ __ ] did
she get double oh seven it's 23 14 55
because fort ethan were you eating
attention
are you [ __ ] serious okay so she's
dividing the 14
by two seven times seven plus seven two
sevens double seven double o what is the
23 doing
uh
[Music]
well i think it's the fact that 23 23
because there was two 23s
double 007.
and then i love how she puts an o in
front of the seven for no reason
because she's saying 14
divided by two because it's a time stamp
and time stamps always have two digits
and so and it's seven oh seven plus okay
she put it too
that adds up she's right
oh seven plus oh seven is first first
initial pose would it be oh fourteen
so you know you just kind of
you have to look at this stuff yeah you
know and it just ties right in i think
it's just amazing and then of course you
know we read this on the main board and
a lot of us were just kind of blowing it
sounds like when someone doesn't read it
in english right and they're doing like
obviously we read this and um it was
great they're bullshitting their way
through a presentation and this person
said that because i think that maybe
they love the other person a little bit
too much
catcher in the rise about a catcher in
the uri
notice i'm not anonymous see that says
you right there but that's because it's
me
looking at it right whenever i see my
own stuff i post it'll tell you you but
everybody else just sees a nom anonymous
this lady should not be on a chan or
fort jenner i mean this lady she's dealt
the problem is that this woman belongs
on facebook
they've gone way too deep in the
internet and they've lost their [ __ ]
minds yeah these are boomers who are
being [ __ ] with by people on 4chan and
8-chan and as a result their brains have
melted okay so let's go over to the
board i'm going to show you
just what i'm talking about so here it
is
here's the number right he was
responding to this anon where it says
hey q does p equal passive or when do we
start seeing the pain where we go one we
go all magna right so he said he clicked
on that guy's number that gal's number
and said yes that's p so look so so
everyone starts responding these are
just kind of some of the responses right
right
they're just responding tons of them
right notice they're all anonymous see
the anonymous see the green anonymous
this is very important for you to
understand people are commenting as
anonymous nobody's
saying anybody's name
nobody knows who anybody is we're all
anonymous what the [ __ ] dude she's what
the [ __ ]
this clip from the 11th video series
learn
r comms and at q anon believer kellyanne
hub news explains why she believes that
q and dorist and a chan poster known as
r watch this
well well well well well well well looky
here what do we got
we have q
look at this
look at the top there's q there is his
trip code
and what is he doing
do you see this one two four two six
eight two
right
well g
where did we just see that
a2 was the ending of it oh well looky
here what is the n i can't do this
uh yeah but just imagine watching a
two-hour video of that and people were
in so i guess shout out to the community
uh other cute theories via telegram
telegram is an app similar to whatsapp
that follows kind of the same theory of
like pedophiles and uh
white supremacists i think
it's like one of those off-brand
whatsapp for just freaks
lots of conservative and q people use it
for communication one telegram user has
offered another theory that jfk jfk jr
and jacqueline kennedy will all appear
and after which jfk will tour the world
for seven days transfer the presidency
back to trump i was talking about right
okay so he's tr he's transferring the
president back to trump and then he will
die
his head will spontaneously explode on
the back of the skull like a
black widow after giving her like you
know
my job here is done
another telegram user has been promising
that the forthcoming event will involve
trump being reinstated as 18th president
united states
hell yeah he would then step down and
appoint jfk jr as the president
and disgrace national security advisor
michael flynn as vice pres
why michael flynn
well because i guess i do know the
answer that because michael flynn has
fully embraced the q and on thing there
you go making a lot of money off of them
just a little update yeah and especially
because you know we don't have um
we don't have leftovers so i gotta get
my fix yeah
well it's pretty entertaining it's
pretty interesting pretty scary it's
pretty scary pretty scary i mean it's a
thousand people you know there's
a lot there's but dude that's like
you came from all around the country
no i know it's it's definitely scary but
i i don't know i i do think that the q
anon thing has
lost a lot of momentum because um
because they made the class they made
the mistake
that all bad cult leaders make which is
to make specific predictions you can't
you always have to stay vague because as
soon as you start putting dates on stuff
and then it doesn't come true you lose
people and so
you know it over and over again they
were like on this day it's happening
hillary clinton i think he's gonna be
shot in the [ __ ] face on national
television
for sure it's happening at this exact
storm on this day and then if that
doesn't happen and it's like yeah they
immediately pivot and start talking
about something else but every time that
happens they they shed some more and
more people so yeah that was a huge big
q uh disillusionment on the the storm
was supposed to happen
but what's their what's their
explanation this time for why jfk jr
didn't rise from the dead and ornate
donald trump the king of kings they
don't need to bother with an explanation
no there's always a story well i it may
have something to do with the uh i still
see
i don't know how often they can use this
excuse but at some point they were
explaining like ah
we actually i apologize we got the date
wrong and the reason we got the date
wrong is
it's actually going by the julian
calendar you know like that's that's
classic culture and it is classic
culture that's what all the dooms
wrong calendar wrong calendar but
there's only so many other calendars you
can uh skip over to before you run out
of calendars too so
i don't know how long ago i was using
the mayan calendar right exactly oh i
must use the gregarian
roman calendar
so
yeah
and like i said it's it's splintered
hardcore too there's like tons of
subgroups in fact i saw that there was a
lot of q on people that were mad at all
these people in dallas because it makes
them look stupid which is really ironic
because let's be honest they all look
stupid anyways but um
you know they're somehow self-aware
enough to be like you guys are making us
look like fools stop stop doing this so
how much time we've got because we i
wanted to do the bizarre roommate story
uh we do not have enough time to do that
damn damn
that's right we only got about 10
minutes
well let's see if we have anything and
actually we have a
we got to calculate ads into that too so
um really well wrapping it up
let me see if there's something else
here that i wanted to go over
we have some cav cap stuff i don't know
if you guys i mean cab cab is always fun
for me
you know
okay let's go cav ryan cavanaugh's
instagram page is blowing up you guys
super organically too
top triller streamer cam grand stop
reply
check for corn
uh he said yo i don't even know what
he's trying to post top trailer us
i don't know what the [ __ ] it means
indiegogo indo didn't they do that
you never know what what they are about
they're so bad no what are they trying
to say here
it's the top song on
oh
yes he's saying snoop dogg ice cube and
e40 have this song
oh i see it and it's number one on
triller right now yeah but what's really
interesting
about first of all this got 10 000 likes
this guy has no engagement nobody cares
about him
he's literally a nobody well he's a
public figure let's make that straight
but nobody cares about it social media
1000 likes is a healthy amount of likes
yeah but here's here you want to look at
the comments yeah let's take a look
there's susie
love it so much thanks for sharing
congrats awesome good job always on top
the best hearts great job is this kind
of what you would expect to see from
instagram no they seem like look at all
the noises
um very real people killing it as always
yes nice work guys let's click on keep
it up you can and then they're all
private
all of them are private look at this and
the follower range is between like 10
and 20k
yeah look they're all private that's so
weird
well maybe these people just like their
privacy right sure but like all of them
i mean here look at them well deserved
they did an amazing job wow that's
awesome congratulations just pure
they're just stoked private damn isn't
it strange that someone that has 10 to
20k wants to make their account private
all of them
yeah you think these people want that
cloud that's real cloud right there in
the top right right now what's happening
that's that real cloud that's what real
cloud that's organic cloud look at that
that's homegrown
wow
and there's just the comments seem to
repeat too this is awesome wow love it
perfection love it wow big likes wild
the best of the best keep it up nice the
best of the best wait that's the same
comment twice
well if it's true
you can understand why multiple people
have that opinion from mia smith one
private account 12k followers huh the
best of the best vera thomas vera
thompson 90. she feels that way private
account 12 k followers
something's off here love weird
coincidence wow you deserve it
stunning confident and perfect
wait hold on elmer joma says that's
absolutely amazing
private damn there's oh 12.2 k there's
something so weird about this comment
section i just can't put my finger on it
you know what i'm saying hard work
always pays off
you always inspire us private damn it's
so weird ryan what's going on with your
instagram page
i'm not i don't know obviously this is
all allegations but if he's buying fake
comments that that would be really
pathetic
that's like really pathetic
yeah that's pretty low i find it strange
that cameron has like the top comment
six
yes nobody has any likes
nobody
i mean he just said check for corn i
feel like that you know that's a sort of
a show meme i'm not why would someone
even like that exactly it's funny
i'm liking it right now
oh i like it yeah
yeah
check for that corn thank you cam
yeah but like there's something sussy in
the comments here and it's just if he is
paying people to comment and like
that's just pathetic and weird mm-hmm
you know like
like and also that's going to be again
that's what he's doing i'm just alleging
it
right
i'm just
speculating but
if you wanted to do a discovery about it
i'm down
[Laughter]
you know if you want to go to discovery
i'll happily ask for
if you have any communications with
marketing companies right followers on
instagram
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this fraud
but
this is just so weird ryan
why are you so vain bro also is it kind
of strange that snoop isn't a big
investor and triller
yeah he is
interesting
yeah his his social media is off the
chain bro
love it somebody um
but this is definitely against terms of
service if he is buying likes and
comments right that would be that would
be against
terms of service
for sure
yeah it's weird um
this one person um
that works at uh one of these click
farms um that's a fan of the show
actually sent me this
oh no way what is this
i you know it's not clear
it's not clear
what's going on here but i mean this is
somebody that says that they work
uh at a click farm
and um first thing in the morning when
they open it they oftentimes see
a bunch of orders for a gentleman named
ryan cavanaugh now it could be any i
don't know if it's
our orion kavanaugh it could be any ryan
cavanaugh but
um what are they asking him to do since
it's coming up what are they asking it's
saying right what are they supposed to
do i don't get it
um
you know i think it's like seo kind of
stuff
um wanted me they actually sent it to me
a while ago yeah um
they're like love maybe you know it's
like you type in it you go to the
youtube you watch it just
enhance seo
yeah i mean every time someone searches
your name spends time on our website
yeah i think you know that's got to be
again from what from what they're
explaining it's actually it's seo
it's like google seo manipulation more
so than uh
yeah it's called black cat seo yeah
right also by the way ryan kavanaugh's
so this isn't this doesn't have anything
to do with instagram just to be clear
he's just doing the he are well as a
dude named ryan cavanaugh but a dude
named ryan what is the video about is it
about him because you can see a youtube
link oh it's kind of x'd out right yeah
they're they're they're hiding these but
um yeah they're
you can see it starts with the w and
ends with oh that's just his watch
fascinating stuff well here's here
here's a it says rank cavanaugh it's a
youtube a a yahoo article obviously
entertainment right and then it says
ryan cavanaugh something here here's
their explanation
uh
an order pops up on his screen
they have to paste in the keyword ryan
kavanagh into google then scroll through
the pages until the ordered link is
highlighted in red so they're looking
for a specific link then i just click
the link and wait about 60 seconds in
order to give it a unique page view i'm
assuming i probably have 30 of these a
day pop up that's so sick job i wonder
if that's good money yeah probably not
probably not great but it's an easy job
pretty easy
but hold on we can find out what that
article is type yahoo.com slash
entertainment rank kavanaugh something
dot html i mean that's clearly
what they're trying to promote there
those those asterisks are not helping
them in that case
right
because that would prove that or i mean
it wouldn't prove but there would be a
strong correlation
that the our ryan kavanaugh is this
right kavanagh
by the way
his instagram is pretty awesome it says
uh no negativity please bring your hate
and jealousy somewhere else no time or
room here
you mean br bring your fake comments
here the best
top of the tops
top of the tops baby
private 12 000 followers
so vain
[Laughter]
oh by the way you want to know what real
a [ __ ] seo looks like ryan kavanagh
if you go to bing look at this [ __ ]
oh i don't see it oh here it is we're on
the front page
that's real seo dude
type in ryan kavanagh this is what seo
looks like people finding what they want
to watch engaging with it and it shows
up on the search results here's ryan
cavanaugh boom does ryan cavanaugh look
like harvey weinstein
that's seo
yeah so if you want to go to google
just type google.com
let's see where we're at
ryankavanaugh
okay
and then
and then let's see
and then you want to describe kind of
what we what we're looking for here uh
love
yeah so right now we're looking for the
does ryan cabinet look like harvey
weinstein website made wait wait wait
wait you titled this right cavanaugh ceo
triller is a person i don't think that's
the title we wanted
i thought that's what just no no it's
supposed to say ryan kavanaugh ceo of
chiller is a bad person
that's definitely what you sent me no i
sent you i corrected myself
oh i missed that i mean it's still
technically true it's technically
i dare you to slap you to sue me for
that one
my bad
okay so here it is we're on the second
page you know i missed the mark with
that
one oh interesting update
i see in the emails that i was sent
there actually was a follow-up he said
this is what one of them looked like
when i clicked on it it does actually
reveal
the click and uh life of the hollywood
innovator ryan kevin
listen to the the metadata ryan
cavanaugh loves one thing as much as he
loves films and that's philanthropy he
loves giving away money what a [ __ ]
guy you know what that's actually true
he loves giving away money to his
lawyers for frivolous lawsuits that he
is inevitable hopefully he's going to
love
paying me back for my lawyer food this
is interesting though i feel like like
you said i mean this is not
proof
this isn't hard proof of course not but
there does seem to be a correlation to
the ryan kavanagh uh
that we're familiar with and the one
that is using the services of this click
farm i guess it could be a third party
it could be somebody other than ryan
that's trying to promote his but somehow
after all we've talked about him
everything on the top is just like these
really flattering articles how triller
became ryan's biggest comeback okay yeah
right
that article that one day was in the seo
was uh 2014 the one that was in the
email sorry right yeah that's trump
trailer and the return of ryan cavanaugh
glorious
excellent stuff if you check his youtube
videos i sent his youtube link there's
some very interesting stuff going on
there as well oh he's back on youtube
i believe so let compare his last two
videos view wise oh [ __ ] yeah he's up to
330 subbies
[ __ ] bro oh yeah these are the ones we
want here's we love supporting
did he turn off comments yeah he did
but wait check the last two videos
the newest two yeah check the compare
the views
um two days one view so that's popping
off the rails
yeah i mean but i mean it's that's kind
of what i would expect
it's strange though how each one's like
1k 1k and then one is 151 and then
another one's one one view that's him
that just means he someone forgot to buy
their views that day in my opinion
here let's watch what a one view video
is like that sports is coming
on the eve of triller fight club he's
gonna sue me for watching his ad
man
by the way google doesn't really [ __ ]
around when they see people buying stuff
like that
yeah and they face if they see that they
will definitely i wonder if i should
just because i wonder if i should send
this info to someone
and just because i don't know what i'll
say just so they can investigate you
should look into this yeah
yeah there's are your own research
directory i know direct emails to people
in search
actually i wonder i wonder if i could um
if i could report that to somebody
let's talk about it after the show which
by the way is right now because uh it's
time to write anyway it's just uh you
know we had 10 minutes to fill
of course i filled it with my favorite
topic the guy who's suing me
twice for frivolous [ __ ] that would
be ryan cavanaugh the ceo of trailer
who's doing so many terrible things you
can read all about what a terrible dude
this guy is
at does rank kavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein.com
and also have it cleared up for you
whether or not he does
in fact look like harvey weinstein
which he
which some people think he does some
people think that only like 90
something percent does i'm in the
minority i don't all right all right
thank you guys for watching we'll be
back on friday for after dark live you
know what it is this is your whoa
i was going to salute but i did this too
hard
oh you should give the result of the uh
clickbait you said you'd tell everyone
at the end
oh so no okay thank you for the reminder
drumroll
okay thank you for everyone for staying
till the end for the big reveal people
people have been talking people have
been gossiping and wondering are me and
ela
separating are me and eli getting a
divorce is she leaving me
no we are still together
and um
we are not planning to separate at this
time we are still together that's
fantastic news man congrats yeah i mean
i think it's great we're making it work
and uh
i'm really happy for you thank you yeah
so so
thanks for everyone for watching at the
end
that's a big so i know everyone's gonna
be super happy about that thank you guys
for watching
not this this
right
thank you
[Music]